hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters ah so I
got a little upset the last game it
happens to the best of us whatever I
went around yeah took a nice relaxing
walk big shower
well better now okay so I got a hurry oh
well isn't that lovely
I died ha ha ha oh well it's it's no
problem for me
oh no the thing is falling welp I better
be on my merry way
oh look it's a friend and now he's dead
ah oh there we go
ok and there we have it I don't even
think I need to do go down that way I
just need to get in there too I said you
can do I'm not sure I think I just need
to get in here to get away from the
falling elevator and that was it
so now that I'm out I can fall and die
yep that sounds about right
ok there goes the elevator all right so
it's couch out here and jump over that
and then I can go back up am airway ok I
was I didn't hear anything I thought the
sound might have cut out huh alright now
going back up so that we can go this
amazingly short distance to the goal
which is wait what wait where am I going
wait what was the point of that it can't
be right
nothing's out right here
oh maybe maybe that switch home excuse
me sorry something my throat maybe that
switch did something for that uh nope oh
oh
catch the letter there we go I can't go
farther down or can i I can okay but
that's still too far yeah see it's to
death okay so I'm guessing it has to do
with this button I don't think it was on
before so I turned that button on and
then I can go up here on to this up no
that breaks - all right never mind then
what the hell all right there's
something there was something in that
vent there something in there no that's
where I came out and that's where the
ladder was that went to the other thing
I'm just wasting battery okay apparently
I can't get up around here so it's got
to be something down here that I've
missed like oh okay that's what that
does
Oh interesting well that was a waste of
flashlights but I still got five I'm
fine
ah this looks scary I'm gonna get me huh
not today you think that I've have a
better melee weapon than a knife to kill
or not to kill to kill greats oh ha no
oh oh that's creepy what the hell okay
definitely avoid them ah oh they're like
the pig thingies oh the electro pigs Oh
oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] just get away just get
away I just get away a good way
oh my goodness ah
ah okay I hit it can I kill you from
here please wait wait bushi Gayle it's
still well still little ones man all the
enemies have huge amounts of healthiness
you know and hard I probably don't need
to kill them
ah I really don't I didn't need to kill
him let me just know I've been I've been
saving and loading too much only save
and load if I die but still I mean oh
sorry
deftly avoiding deftly avoiding lock is
jammed
oh not fair not fair
I've got five health oh boy what about
that that door over there over there
over there open open the wrong way
oh boy ah ah ah you I thought the door
had closed
ah okay definitely avoiding definitely a
boy dang definitely able ah damn it
okay come over here to this corner that
way you can explode in solitude I'll
lead you around in a circle and then oh
oh okay got that
kick it out and then run dodge like a
boss almost miss that oh now you open
the correct way and then ah no there we
go Oh close it or close it or don't come
in here bro
don't do it can I get help from the bot
machines please I remember these from
half-life no okay Chuck and shells I'll
take those yeah boxes gonna break you
yes health bills all these bucks
nothing else though okay another button
okay that opened that door and also got
some weird camera stuff going on there
I'm guessing this wasn't meant to be
played in group on an HD monitor okay
Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron yes oh not
that way this way
oh uh oh come on I got shotgun [ __ ]
hell you're like part of your body
doesn't get hit
what oh where did you come from
what where did where the heck did he
come from like series whoa ah damn it I
can't watch both directions at the same
time screw it screw it screw this and
screw all you ah screw you too
oh damn it screw all y'all nope yep
that's right on the balls ah ah it's two
of you things huh keep going keep going
ha ha ha huh I made it that's a double
back huh ah what is that looks like a
floating head
seriously what is that is that a
what what whoo oh my god is there
something over there that like some
goodie huh all right ah damn and I
quicksave right then of course I did
okay let's see if there's something over
here some over here anything anything
anything nope nope nothing I was a
mistake leaving okay whoa whoa okay ah
damn it oh I'll just kill me just just
kill me just kill me come on
oh you're that bad of a shot now really
I could just stand here and it would do
nothing to me really there that it took
that long to just kill me Ari I'm
getting out here but move I hate it when
you look quick slave or when it loads it
can't always do it ah good eye here no
no I mean haha yeah that audio is weird
there we go that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm talking about huh
what Wow oh come on back down and health
is gone again hock does not help whoa
you come here come here I got something
for ya and it used to be one that was
kind of a headshot oh I can't still be
in here what's in here then okay
whatever
come on oh here we go oh yes this little
health let me actually do a real save I
brought you saved before pills Oh No Oh
what are you oh my goodness Oh what was
that
ah ah oh okay
anything in here ah why is it swinging
why you be swinging
Oh another door with a missing lock I
don't need your sass oh my god is that
your head is that even qualify as a
headshot oh my god that's like that
looks like I'm a character model gone
horrifyingly wrong I was down here which
way do I go
oh come at me bro
Oh No BAM bump bank bump boot yeah yeah
HUP HUP oh look a lot o bleeding whoa
whoa what something happened it changed
it did what what what's going on
[Music]
Oh
I'm so startled is that thermostat okay
nothing in here okay
ooh anything behind the mirror medicine
cabinet maybe no okay apparently nothing
else in here
I swear that Mona Lisa something
happened it was like just the most split
of seconds but something happened ah
damn you damn you da ha oh yeah yeah oh
if anyone doubted that a half-life one
mob come on
could be terrifying I think this is
evidence where does this go
why are there two directions that I seem
to be able to go miss I never miss oh
man Oh up up no I'm not gonna do you're
exploding there we go
that's more like it okay I'm really
curious like it's given me two
directions to go but like what do I do
about that I feel like I should check
out both directions before I commit to
one
I don't know I just don't know I mean
this is ah oh no you know one two three
four five or less more I don't know
section D doors locked
okay so I'm guessing that I got to get a
key to go somewhere else was that this
order controlled [ __ ] okay
I don't know I don't know what that's
all about so I'm down here
all right that's all the time I got for
this episode haha I don't want to go
down there anyway thank you guys so much
for watching as always I appreciate
every single one of you and I will see
you in the next part bye bye